The main exporter of Brazil nuts is not Brazil.
It's Bolivia.
Vikings who died in bed rather than battle
went to a special afterlife where it was always
foggy.
The difference between the hardwood and softwood
has to do with its seeds, and has nothing
to do with how hard or soft the wood is.
Almost a third of the worlds languages are
spoken only in Africa.
Air pollution kills 4000 Chinese people per
day.
Giraffe are already extinct in at least seven
countries in Africa.
A recent study found that sitting straight
up at 90 degrees is bad for your back.
You should slouch at an angle of 135 degrees
to provide maximum support for your spine.
Cremation causes silicone breast implants
to explode.
According to Switzerland's law, social animals
like guinea pigs must live with a buddy.
Owning only one is considered animal abuse
and is illegal.
Canada has the longest coastline of any country
in the world.
The original recipe for chocolate contained
chili powder instead of sugar.
Shark pregnancies last for up to 4 years.
Even though the west is accustomed to apples,
oranges and bananas the most commonly eaten
fruit around the world is actually mangos.
Hospital, a village in Ireland, doesn't have
a hospital.
The CIA operation to invade Cuba and take
down Castro was called “Operation Castration”.